and the cognition side is where the leap
seems to happen with humans that it does
seem we're kind of special and that's a
really interesting question when
thinking about alien life or if there's
other intelligent alien civilizations
out there is how special is this leap so
one special thing seems to be the origin
of life itself however you define that
there's a gray area and the other leap
this is very biased perspective of a
human is the the
origin of intelligence
and again from an engineer perspective
it's a difficult question to ask an
important one
is how difficult does that leap how
special were humans
did uh did a monolith come down did
aliens bring down a monolith and some
apes had to touch a monolith but
to get it it's a lot like dark descartes
uh you know idea right exactly i it's
but it just seems
that it seems one heck of a leap yeah to
get to this level of intelligence yeah
and you know so chomsky um
uh argued um
that you know some
uh
genetic fluke occurred a hundred
thousand years ago
and
you know just happened that some
human some
hominin
predecessor of current humans had this
one genetic
tweak
that resulted in
language yeah and
language
then provided
this special thing that separates us
from all other animals
um
i'm
i think there's a lot of truth to the
value and importance of language
but i think it comes along with
the evolution of a lot of other related
things related to sociality
and mutual engagement with others
and um
establishment of um
i don't know rich
mechanisms for
organizing an understanding of the world
which language then plugs into right so
it's uh
language is a tool
that allows you to do this kind of
collective intelligence and whatever is
at the core of
the thing that allows for this
collective intelligence is the main
thing and it's interesting to think
about that one fluke
one mutation can lead to the like the
the first crack open
opening of the door
to human intelligence like all it takes
is one like evolution just kind of opens
the door a little bit and then it time
and selection takes care of the rest
you know there's so many fascinating
aspects to these kinds of things
we think of evolution as continuous
right we think oh yes okay over
500 million years there could have been
this
you know relatively continuous
changes and
um
but that's not what
anthropologists
evolutionary biologists found from the
fossil record they found
you know hundreds of years of uh
hundreds of millions of years of stasis
yeah and then you know suddenly a change
occurs well suddenly on that scale is a
million years or something
but but or even 10 million years but
but um
the concept of punctuated equilibrium
was a very important concept in
evolutionary biology
uh
and uh that
also feels
somehow right about
you know
the stages of our mental abilities we
we seem to have a certain kind of
mindset at a certain age and then
at another
another age we like look at that
four-year-old and say oh my god how
could they have thought that way
so piaget was known for this kind of
stage theory of child development right
and
you look at it closely and suddenly
those stages aren't so discreet and the
transitions but the difference between
the four-year-old and the seven-year-old
is profound and
that's another thing that's always
interested me is how we
something happens over the course of
several years of experience where at
some point we reach the point where
something like an insight or a
transition or a new stage of development
occurs and uh
you know these kinds of things can be
understood
in complex systems
research and so
evolutionary biology developmental
biology
cognitive development are all things
that have been approached in this kind
of way yeah
just like you said i find both
fascinating
those early years
of human life but also the early like
minutes days of from the embryonic
development
to like how from embryos you get like
the brain that development
again from the engineering perspective
it's fascinating so it's not so the
early
when you deploy the brain to the human
world and it gets to explore that world
and learn that's fascinating but just
like the assembly of the mechanism that
is capable of learning that's like
amazing the stuff they're doing with
like brain organoids
where you can
build many brains and study that
um
self-assembly of a mechanism from like
the dna material that that's like
what the heck
you have literally like biological
programs
that just generate a system
this mushy thing
that's able to be robust and learn in a
very unpredictable world
and learn seemingly arbitrary things or
like
a very large number of things that
enable survival yeah
ultimately um
that is a very important part of the
whole process of you know understanding
this sort of
emergence of mind from brain kind of
kind of thing and the whole thing seems
to be pretty continuous
you